[Musik]
die suche nach dem warum einen tag nach
dem amoklauf von würzburg durchleuchten
ermittler das leben des täters landung
in der heimat die ersten der in mali
verletzten bundeswehrsoldaten sind zum
medizinischen versorgung nach
deutschland gebracht worden
hallo ist da jemand der amerikanische
geheimdienst veröffentlicht seinen
bericht über ufo-sichtungen der letzten
17 jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an diesem 26 juni norbert
lehmann ist auch dabei für den sport ein
schöner andere von mir
der amoklauf in würzburg halt nach nicht
nur der bundespräsident zeigt sich
erschüttert auch über die brutalität des
täters eine von mindestens fünf schwer
verletzten schwebt noch in lebensgefahr
drei frauen erlagen gestern und tatort
ihren verletzungen
es war gegen 17 uhr mitten in der
würzburger innenstadt am barbarossaplatz
sticht ein 24-jähriger somalia zuerst in
einem kaufhaus scheinbar wahllos auf
menschen ein
dann in einer bank und auf der straße
passanten versuchten ihn aufzuhalten
schließlich kann in die polizei mit
einem schuss ins bein stoppen und
überwältigen oder sonne wald blumen und
kerzen im gedenken an diejenigen die
hier gestern ihr leben verloren haben
viele kommen an den barbarossaplatz in
der würzburger innenstadt um ihr
mitgefühl auszudrücken mir tun die
menschen leid die hier stern mussten
unnötig stärken mussten mitunter
angehörigen leid der angreifer hat
brutal auf unbekannte menschen
eingestochen
dabei ging er gezielt auf frauen los
mutige passanten hielten ihn auf bis die
polizei kam und ihn mit einem
oberschenkel schoss stoppte die
betreiber eines gegenüberliegenden
lokals haben das geschehen hautnah
miterlebt und gefilmt mach die tür zu
und wird so schließlich tür ab und dann
rennt einer mit messer und alle
mitbewohner und so werfen mit
stühle und hocker und alles auf dieser
mann bei dem mutmaßlichen täter gegen
den heute haftbefehl erlassen wurde
handelt es sich um einen 24-jährigen
somalia der legal in deutschland lebt
seit 2015 in würzburg zuletzt in dieser
obdachlosenunterkunft er soll psychisch
auffällig und in psychiatrischer
behandlung gewesen sein bei dem angriff
soll allahu akbar gerufen haben
zudem fanden die ermittler in seiner
unterkunft hinweise auf ein
islamistisches motiv das auch noch dort
schrift material mit hassbotschaften
wären dieses material haben wir
sichergestellt
es ist aber noch nicht ausgewertet unter
den sechs schwerverletzten ist auch ein
elfjähriger junge seine mutter wurde bei
dem amoklauf getötet eine person schwebt
noch in lebensgefahr
die gedanken sind bei den toten bei den
verletzten bei deren angehörigen
wir hoffen und beten dass die die
schwerst verletzt sind wieder genesen
und gesunden morgen soll es im
würzburger dom einen gedenkgottesdienst
geben für die opfer dieses schrecklichen
amoklaufs patricia schäfer in würzburg
gelassen wir uns nochmal über den
mutmasslichen täter reden
es heißt er sei in der vergangenheit
schon auffällig gewesen was war da als
er war ja schon seit 2015 in deutschland
aber erst in diesem jahr 20 21 sehr
auffällig geworden
dafür gleich zweimal im januar hat er
sich bei einem streit mit bewohnern und
personal der obdachlosenunterkunft wo er
wohnte ein messer gegriffen hat die
anderen bedroht aber nichts gemacht
daraufhin wurde er in eine
psychiatrische anstalt eingewiesen aber
nach einer woche wieder entlassen
im juni dann hat er sich einem auto in
den weg gestellt hat sich einfach auf
den beifahrersitz gesetzt und ist nicht
mehr ausgestiegen auch da kam er kurz in
die psychiatrie nach einem tag wurde er
da wieder entlassen
es gibt eine psychiatrisches gutachten
an dem gearbeitet wird das wurde im
januar eben in auftrag gegeben seit fünf
monaten wird daran
gearbeitet aber es ist noch nicht fertig
offensichtlich haben die ärzte keinerlei
gründe gesehen für selbst oder
fremdgefährdung und man musste ihn
wieder entlassen
was sagen die ermittler zum möglichen
motiv hat da wird heftig ermittelt eben
man es gibt sowohl hinweise auf einen
islamistischen auf einen islamistischen
hintergrund hat in dem kaufhaus hier
hinter mir bei der tat ja angeblich
allahu akhbar geschrieben nach einer
zeugen geschrieben nach einer
zeugenaussage
es wurde ein handy in seiner wohnung
sichergestellt dass jetzt ausgelesen
wird die kommunikation darauf ist
natürlich nicht in deutscher sprache
deshalb dauert das ein bisschen man weiß
es nicht aber es gibt eben auch wie
gesagt diese hinweise auf diese
psychischen auffälligkeiten
es kann sagt innenminister herrmann
natürlich auch eine mischung von beidem
sein es ist oft nicht so klar man kann
ihn nicht in die eine oder in die andere
schublade stecken
möglicherweise spielt beides eine rolle
das wird jetzt in den nächsten tagen
ermittelt
danke für diese informationen aus
würzburg patricia schäfer nach mali wie
es mit dem bundeswehr einsatz dort
weitergehen soll das wird jetzt in
berlin diskutiert der selbstmordanschlag
mit zwölf zum teil schwer verletzten
deutschen soldaten hat gezeigt wie
gefährlich die un friedensmission in
mali ist das westafrikanische land ist
geprägt von kämpfen islamistische
terrorgruppen
nach dem bombenattentat nordöstlich von
gao wurden die ersten verwundeten heute
ausgeflogen
david gepaart berichtet zurück auf
deutschen booten einige schwer verletzt
aber am leben
die ersten der zwölf durch einen
selbstmord anschlag verwundeten
bundeswehrsoldaten landen heute in köln
soll nun im bundeswehrkrankenhaus weiter
behandelt werden
der von vielen fast vergessene einsatz
in mali drängt zurück ins öffentliche
bewusstsein
es ist der gefährlichste einsatz ist ein
einsatz gegen islamistische
terroristische gruppen es ist ein
einsatz zur stabilisierung von mali als
start und gleichzeitig sehen wir dass
durch die entwicklung in mali die
gesamte region kurz vor dem kollaps
steht
in berlin läuft derweil die politische
debatte über mögliche konsequenzen für
auslandseinsätze
wir hätten die rolle eines vermittlers
bei konflikten übernehmen sollen und
nicht die eines weltpolizisten wir
müssen unsere soldaten zurückziehen
ein überstürzter abzug aus mali sei ein
fehler da sind sich die drei
kontrahenten ums kanzleramt bei einer
diskussion heute einig die un
stabilisierungsmission sei grundsätzlich
wichtig doch es gibt auch dissenz mit
blick auf den eu heute mali einsatz der
ja nochmal darüber hinaus geht wo es
auch ausbildung von streitkräften von
diktatorischen regime geht das halten
wir sowie der bundestag oder die
bundesregierung das beschlossen hat
nicht so richtig wir wollen die lage in
mali stabilisieren und das kann sich
aber im laufe dieser jahre immer wieder
verändern
und deshalb muss man darauf flexibel
antworten mit der bereitschaft wenn die
sicherheit so bedroht dass man mehr
machen muss dass man dann auch mehr tut
das ist ein hochgefährlicher einsatz
auch wenn er nicht sehr groß ist und
dass es bei jeder entscheidung die wir
treffen immer auch darum geht dass wir
verantwortung haben für das leben und
die sicherheit der soldaten soldaten
so werden soldaten in einem eigenen
bundeswehr video 2017 in mali begrüßt
es bleibt der wohl gefährlichste einsatz
und die frage nach der perspektive die
mütter rente sie ist ein zankapfel der
unions-parteien die csu will sie auch
auf ältere mütter ausweiten die cdu ist
dagegen
csu-parteichef söder gibt sich
unnachgiebig die erweiterte mütter rente
sei grundbedingung für eine
regierungsbeteiligung die cdu hatte
verhindert dass diese forderung ins
gemeinsame wahlprogramm kommt zur krone
lage da macht die delta variante der
bundesregierung sorgen sie schränkt
deshalb die einreise aus russland und
portugal massiv ein
in der hauptstadt lissabon sind 70
prozent der neuinfektionen bereits data
mutationen das robert koch institut
stuft portugal ab kommenden dienstag als
virusvarianten gebiet ein gleiches gilt
für russland heißt wer von dort nach
deutschland zurückkommt muss 14 tage in
quarantäne
die kann auch durch tests nicht verkürzt
werden experten sind sich einig eine
vierte corona welle im herbst wird wohl
kommen eben wegen jener delta variante
was heißt das für die schulen wie sieht
es etwa mit luftfiltern aus für die
kultusminister der länder ist klar nach
den ferien soll es wieder vollständigen
präsenzunterricht geben
das hoffen auch eltern und schüler und
fürchten zugleich dass der stress mit
homeschooling von vorn beginnt oliver
deuker bismarckschule hannover man ist
so gut es geht auf das neue schuljahr
vorbereitet dass sie anfang september
beginnt wie jene maßnahmen weiter
schnelltests zusätzliche
lernunterstützung aber es fehlen
lüftungsanlagen der schulleiter würde
die gerne wenigstens für die klassen an
schaffen in denen die kinder unter zwölf
jahren sind und für die es bisher keinen
impfstoff gibt bisher ist es so wir
dürfen die nicht anschaffen ich wäre
sehr froh wenn sie im winter angeschafft
werden könnten denn dann brauchen wir
sie auf jeden fall bis dahin kommende
temperaturmäßig noch ganz gut zurecht
der grund es fehlt das geht zwar stellt
der bund für solche geräte ein budget
von 500 millionen euro bereit viel zu
spät kritisiert
eltern- und lehrerverbände das
beantragen bewilligen einkauf mit
einbauen bis zum beginn des neuen
schuljahres sei dafür die zeit viel zu
knapp über 23.000 allgemeinbildenden
schulen bundesweit eigentlich brauchen
wir auch unbürokratische hilfen dh die
schulen brauchen einen budget auf das
sie zugreifen können und dann alles an
zu schaffen was sie vor ort brauchen
seien es luftfilter anlagen oder eben
zusätzliches personal wir haben den
eindruck die schulen sind noch nicht
krisenfest eigene landesprogramme dazu
viel anzeige kein geld stattdessen vage
aussichten selbstverständlich werden wir
auch die richtlinie die über den bund
gekommen ist entsprechend in
niedersachsen auch bewerben und das
unterstützen werden so landes seit ich
angucken wo können wir das mit gegenüber
den schulträgern unterstützen
es bleibt die hoffnung dass eine
mögliche vierte corona welle mit der
ansteckenden del der variante nicht so
stark ausfällt den schülern und deren
eltern sind erneute schulschließungen
kaum zuzumuten in die usa als angemessen
bezeichnet us-präsident beiden das
strafmaß im prozess um die tötung des
afroamerikaners coach freut 22 einhalb
jahre muss der polizist ins gefängnis
der für schleiz tod verantwortlich ist
kreuz familie fordert allerdings
weiterhin lebenslange haft und hofft auf
ein weiteres verfahren bei einer
festnahme im mai 2020 hatte die rektorin
sein knie mehrere minuten auf den nacken
kreuz gepresst die zeit schwindet und
die hoffnung auch nahe miami beach in
florida suchen rettungskräfte weiter in
den trümmern des eingestürzten
hochhauses nach verschütteten
159 menschen gelten weiter als vermisst
vier opfer sind bisher tot geborgen
worden
viele bewohner des zwölfstöckigen
appartement gebäudes wurden in der nacht
zu donnerstag von dem einsturz wohl im
schlaf überrascht die ursache bleibt
unklar
im süden tschechiens geht das aufräumen
weiter nach dem verheerenden tornado mit
fünf toten und etwa 200 verletzten
unter den trümmern werden keine
verschütteten mehr vermutet statiker
prüfen nun welche gebäude
einsturzgefährdet sind
in sieben ortschaften wurden hunderte
häuser
teilweise oder sogar ganz zerstört viele
einwohner haben keine bleibe mehr ritter
hilfe berichtet am tag zwei nach dem
tornado trösten sie sich noch ein
rutschte dem ort der wohl am stärksten
zerstört ist ein drittel der einwohner
habt ihr zuhause verloren
mitten durch das dorf zog der tornado
auch das haus von thomas beck ist
zerstört die familie überlebt in einem
zimmer ohne fenster und türen in aproz
diesmal es ist ein gefühl wie vernichtet
da ist angst ohnmacht und verzweiflung
aber wir hatten auch glück
wir leben mit circa 300
stundenkilometern fegte der tornado am
donnerstag durch sieg wäre 500 meter
breite und 26 kilometer lang ist die
schneise der zerstörung
kurz nach dem abendessen trifft es auch
dieses seniorenheim
die bewohner sind unverletzt und haben
bereits eine andere bleibe aber es wird
monate dauern bis sie zurückkehren
können der wiederaufbau in den sieben
betroffenen dörfern steht ganz am anfang
1000 feuerwehrleute sind noch im einsatz
ebenso wie hunderte soldaten der armee
aber richtig schwer wird es erst wenn
der schutt einmal wird geräumt ist
es ist alles eine frage des geldes
es wird monate dauern die frage ist aber
auch ob man überhaupt baumaterial
gekostet
schnelle hilfe soll kommen auch von der
eu verspricht tschechiens premier prüfen
alle möglichkeiten so denn der schaden
geht ins unermessliche von hunderten
millionen euro für den wiederaufbau ist
schon jetzt die rede aber vieles was
hier verloren ging bleibt unersetzlich
ufos unbekannte flugobjekte am himmel
immer wieder geben sie rätsel auf wer
oder was dahinter stecken könnte
das us-verteidigungsministerium
beschäftigt sich seit jahrzehnten mit
spannung wurde jetzt der
abschlussbericht der geheimdienste
erwartet sie haben ufo-sichtungen seit
2004 ausgewertet
über das ergebnis abstimmen was fliegt
da über amerika antworten hatten sich
viele erhofft von der ufo kommission
doch was pentagon und
geheimdienste präsentieren produziert
vor allem neue große fragen 144
sogenannte unidentifizierte luft
phänomene wurden untersucht 143 davon
kann der bericht überhaupt nicht
erklären nur einmal sei es wohl ein
ballon gewesen haben gerade mal an der
oberfläche gekratzt bei der erforschung
des universums sagen experten für
außerirdische aktivitäten da draußen
gibt es keine beweise ausschließen aber
könne man auch nichts um natur und
wetterphänomene oder auch neue
militärtechnik der russen oder chinesen
könnte es sich handeln so genannte
extrem schnelle hyperschall waffen eine
bedrohung wäre das dann für die
nationale sicherheit
lange war das thema tabu jetzt haben wir
nicht nur einen bericht sondern
hochrangige regierungsmitarbeiter die
sagen da existiert etwas und wir wissen
nicht was es ist
solche aufnahmen der us airforce hatten
den druck erhöht auf die militärführung
in washington
sie zeigen objekte die außergewöhnlich
sind physikalisch schwer
nachvollziehbare manöver fliegen
der ufo bericht wurde jetzt an den
kongress übermittelt aber eben ohne
antwort auf die frage was da so alles
fliegt über amerika spooky norwegen sind
wir beim fußball norbert und der frage
was macht die nationalmannschaft drei
tage vor dem achtelfinale gegen england
die versucht vor allem eins nämlich den
kopf frei zu bekommen nach dem beinahe
vorrunden-aus gegen ungarn deshalb
gestern ruhetag heute training in
herzogenaurach und ein ganz volksnah
auftritt des teams
sie hatten heute tatsächlich alle hände
voll zu tun die deutschen
nationalspieler und ganz offensichtlich
spaß autogrammstunde war angesagt mit
vielen kleinen die ganz groß raus kam
hat eine nette abwechslung sicherlich
nachdem heute vormittag schon wieder
mächtig geschwitzt wurde getreu dem
motto nach dem spiel ist vor dem spiel
es ist abgehakt wir wissen dass es knapp
war
das ist uns durchaus bewusst aber wir
schauen oft auf dienstag ganz klar die
mannschaft von joachim löw wird bis zum
achtelfinale alle übungseinheiten hier
in herzogenaurach absolvieren müssen ein
abschlusstraining im wembley stadion
wurde untersagt der strapazierte
englische rasen benötigt ruhe
ja und gleich in london das achtelfinal
spiel italien gegen österreich das zdf
überträgt ab 20 uhr 15
thomas skulski im rahmen des stage und
klare sache wer der favorit ist oder oh
ja und die einzige frage ist so möchte
man meinen setzen die italiener jetzt
gleich alle drei ihrer eindrucksvollen
erfolgsserien fort seit 30 spielen sind
sie ungeschlagen die letzten elf spiele
haben sie allesamt gewonnen und in
diesen elf spielen nicht ein einziges
gegentor kassiert nicht ein einziges
seit 17 eineinhalb stunden und für
österreich ist das hier heute abend
schon der größte abend in der fußball
geschichte
das erste ko-spiel bei einem großen
turnier seit der weltmeisterschaft 1954
langes ca
danke thomas deutschlands beste
tennisspielerin angelique kerber hat das
atp turnier in bad homburg gewonnen
im finale bezwang sie die tschechin
katerina sinja koffer souverän mit 6 3
und 6 2
ihren letzten titel hatte kerber in
wimbledon 2008 10 gewonnen
ja und dort tritt sie dann nächste woche
an das deutsche mixed doppel nina im
mittel haben und dank chu hat bei der
tischtennis em in warschau gold und
damit die erste medaille für den
deutschen tischtennis bund geholt die
beiden sätzen nicht gestern abend im
finale gegen die slowakei durch
auftakt der 108 der fonds in brest
überschattet von zwei schweren
massenstürzen auch weltmeister julia
verliebt war betroffen konnte aber
weiterfahren und gewann die erste etappe
vor michael matthews und dem tour
vorjahreszweiten primus schoppitsch das
was du nicht
vielen dank dann wie clever es sein kann
den umschlag eine einladung zu einem
kostümball aufzuheben zeigte sich heute
in ludwigsburg auf dem umschlag lebt
nämlich diese briefmarke die sogenannte
rote mauritius 8,1 millionen euro war
sie einem sammler bei der auktion wird
er soll nur noch drei exemplare geben
mit den marken wurden 1847 tatsächlich
einladungen verschickt bei einer
lupenreine sommerwetter verspricht uns
gleich katja horneffer für morgen lange
allerdings lassen die nächsten gewitter
nicht auf sich warten
das heute journal um 10 vor 10 mit
christian sievers danke für ihr
interesse wir wünschen ihnen noch ein
schönes wochenende
bis morgen werden auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren dieses hoch hier
bringt uns ein richtig ruhiges
wochenende allerdings lassen die
gewitter nicht allzu lange auf sich
warten denn dieses gewittertief
erreichen morgen bereits frankreich
montag in der nacht auf dienstag und
dienstag über tag breiten sich die
unwetter dann wieder über fast ganz
mitteleuropa aus nicht so heute nacht
dices ruhig hin und wieder bildet sich
sogar möbel und die temperaturen sinken
auf 16 grad im rhein main gebiet oder
auch auf den ostfriesischen inseln und
bis 9 grad im westerzgebirge morgen
liegen die werte an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee bei angenehmen 22 bis 24 grad
sonst wird es mit 25 bis 30 grad
sommerlich war der tag beginnt mit viel
sonnenschein und erst mal nur ganz
kleinen harmlosen quellwolken
nachmittags und zum abend könnte dass
sich etwas ändern und zwar hier westlich
des rheins oder auch im schwarzwald da
sind dann einige gewitter durchaus
möglich dass mit den gewittern wird sich
dann aber in den nächsten tagen
verschärfen am montag liegt der
schwerpunkt wohl in nordrhein westfalen
und dem rheinland pfalz in der nacht zu
dienstag und dienstag über tag breiten
sich die gewitter weiter aus nur der
nordosten bleibt noch verschont
schönes wochenende